I keep failing what should I do
so I got a great question for one of my
youtube viewers love you guys
Trent's who wrote in to say what do you
do when you've lost all passion doing a
continual failure this is such an
important question and one that I think
almost every entrepreneur can relate to
because this is the ultimate test of if
you are actually passionate about your
business or not it happens so often that
you start a business you're all excited
about it and you think you're gonna make
a lot of money with it and you start and
and it's not as easy you thought it was
gonna be it's way harder than you ever
it's way harder than your worst case
scenario on paper it's way harder than
that and the test is are you passionate
about this enough to keep going because
you're gonna get hit with failure after
failure after punch in the face over and
over and over again and the only thing
that keeps you going is the passion the
love of what you're doing a lot of
famous entrepreneurs say you'd be crazy
to start a business unless you are
massively passionate about what you're
doing and a couple examples come to mind
Oprah Winfrey when she started her talk
show when she started interviewing
people she said that she felt like she
was breathing and she would find other
jobs just to make ends meet to keep
doing that Steve Jobs calls
entrepreneurs a little bit crazy you
have to be crazy because who would who
would put up with all the crap that you
have to go through and deal with the
only thing that gets you to keep going
to keep pushing through is your deep
passion for what you're doing that's why
most people quit because most people are
not super passion about their business
they're in it just trying to make a lot
of money and they don't because it's
hard and the thing that gets you through
is that passion when I first started
helping entrepreneurs I had three people
come out to to my event for a free event
that was at the YMCA with a lot of
promotion three people came out and I
felt like a failure but I loved it so
much that I knew I had to find a way to
keep going so it's a test are you
actually still passionate about your
business or not because if you are
then you have to find another way to
stand you have to find a business model
that will work a business model that
supports your passion right for me I
couldn't do what I do and make money if
I just stuck with doing YMCA
presentations right there was no model
to make money there three people show up
to a free event you look at that from an
outsider you say how are you ever gonna
turn this into a business I found other
ways to stand I created the website I
have my youtube channel I have a radio
show I do partnerships with big brands I
coach entrepreneurs in my movement
program right there's other ways to do
it
still pursuing my passion and that's
what 1012 years later if you have lost
your passion then stop tweaking the
business model stop trying to find a
mate awake make it work and go do
something else
because if you're not if you're not
loving it if you're not feeling that
passion it's over and it's better to
realize that now I move on to something
that you are passionate about and that
can happen too right you could be in the
business and love it and be super
passionate about it and then you change
the market changes you know you don't
like it as much you you grow out of it
the passion fades that's cool move to
something else
follow your passion always whenever you
have a big decision that you have to
make in your business or your life you
have to listen to this you listen to
your heart first even if it doesn't make
any sense on paper you listen to your
heart you've got to follow your passion
now I've been fortunate that I still
love entrepreneurs right I've been in
this game for I said twelve years and
and I still love it like I love
answering these questions I love me with
entrepreneurs I can meet with
entrepreneurs all day long I just yeah
feels me right I get so much energy from
you guys in the comments you leave and
and being able to help you guys out I
love it hopefully you can feel my
passion boom boom boom boom coming out
here but if that fades if I ever look at
it like oh I gotta do another video man
this trance wants an answer and and
that's my attitude going in then I can't
do it anymore
and I have to do something else
and if I stop beloved entrepreneurs then
I gotta go find something else that I
love doing and I can jump all in on
because that's how you're gonna create
amazing work so your question is what do
you do when you've lost passion because
you failed a lot well have you actually
lost your passion if you haven't then
find another way to say it but if you
have then move on to something else
follow a new passion because that's
gonna guide you towards a happy life and
having an impact on this world believe
those you're watching like the video
subscribe to the channel see more just
like it thank you so much I'll see you
soon make sure to check out my
newsletter ya got 11 hi I'm Jason Grif
on sigur rós online.com and I want to
say Evan Carmichael's newsletter is
consistent fun inspiring and it's only
newsletter I prioritize and look forward
to period